ja ich brauche eine nämlich war heute
ist tag der badewanne badewanne party
tag
so badekugeln sind gekauft und der typ
in dem lagerfeuer dankeschön für die
gute beratung und für die pinke hand so
jetzt brauche ich eigentlich nur noch
weg und dann kann ich wieder nach hause
und feierte partys einkäufe erledigt
checke ich war noch in der staat musste
so ein handy vertrags dinge klären und
jetzt mache ich noch einen instagram
posten denn es gibt was zu gewinnen war
sehr schwer ist wenn man keine ahnung
hat wie man das buch zu machen
das ist wohl die frischeste peters hier
die ich je gesehen habe dass sogar noch
erde dran
das wird richtig hübsch wartet der
berufsalltag unserem youtube als auch
finde ich super
schaut mal auf einem instagram account
vorbei denn ein gewinnspiel ihr könnt
nämlich nächste woche zusammen mit nico
m
habt ihr euch das nicht schon immer
gewünscht das leben eines youtube hast
du kannst es eigentlich niemandem
erklären oder
ich werde jetzt noch das foto hochladen
und dann geht an die dekoration
vorzeichen video drehen
die loks hochzuladen ich habe neuen
fernseher so ok ich sage ich jetzt
einmal das badezimmer ich drehe auch
gleich habe ich mit der großen kamera
und ja ich wollte euch nur ganz kurz das
badezimmer zeigen die andere seite
tatsächlich lieber nicht ich bin gerade
umgezogen das noch alles so schrecklich
okay ich will wechseln jetzt zu den
großen kamera
o
ich will nur sagen wir fangen mit der
gelangten da hatte ich die gelände hin
noch einmal war
als nächstes sind also flamini muss dran
seid ihr bereit
mensch dieser party spaß party
ich habe es mir jeden tag wieder
hochziehen
ich habe es echt gemerkt dass es zu viel
isst jeden tag kann ich gar nicht im
video geladen das ist viel zu viel
arbeit
das merke ich jetzt ich bin total kaputt
und es ist noch nicht mal 17 uhr also
ich hoffe ihr seid mir nicht böse dass
ich nicht jeden tag ein video geladen
kann ich habe es versucht das ist
einfach unmöglich glaube ich schneide
jetzt dieses video fertig war das hoch
und dann mache ich mir wirklich wasser
in die badewanne und entspannen mich mal
für fünf minuten weil irgendwie habe ich
das gefühl dass mir der kopf platzt ich
bin ja gerade umgezogen also vor zwei
wochen ungefähr ja vor zwei wochen
und es ist noch so viel zu tun hier in
der wohnung ihr wollt gar nicht wissen
wie die aussieht
ich habe nicht mal ein kleiderschrank
mein kleiderschrank ist gerade ein
kleiner haufen und wenn ich jeden tag
video hochladen möchte habe ich halt
auch da nichts mehr und ich habe sowieso
nichts mehr vom leben
gut dann sind wir uns das nächste mal
wieder zu irgendeinem regulären video
vielleicht fahre ich noch mal ein
kurioses feiertag wer weiß was macht ihr
eigentlich spaß und ich brauche mehr
zeit um das zu machen party man sieht
mich immer noch wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr
diesen kanal abonnieren und ihr könnt
auch die anderen videos anschauen wir
sehen uns dann das nächste mal wieder
bis dahin tschüss